[MUSIC PLAYING]
GREG KNOKE: Hi, my name's
Greg Knoke.
I'm the Google Drive developer
relations technical writer and
with me today is--
STEVE BAZYL: Steve Bazyl, I've
been here before of course.
GREG KNOKE: And today we're
going to talk to about about a
new feature we launched
for the real-time API.
We've recently added an undo and
redo feature to the API.
That makes it really easy to
implement this feature for
your own applications.
And I think the best way to
demonstrate this is to jump
right into a live demonstration
on my screen.
So, if you'll bear with me.
STEVE BAZYL: Go ahead.
GREG KNOKE: So right now on my
screen, what you can see is we
have the realtime quickstart
that you've
possibly seen before.
It's part of our
documentation.
And I have two accounts live
on the quickstart.
So you'll notice we have our
standard text area and at the
bottom we've added these new
Undo and Redo buttons.
So if you look here I'll type in
a little bit of text here,
and you can see that now the
Undo button has become
highlighted for only
one these screens.
That's because these are
two separate accounts.
So on the other account
you can see
that Undo is not active.
That's because the Undo button
only undoes local changes.
So you can see if I go
back to my other
account, undo a few changes.
It's synchronized between both,
but only one account can
actually undo.
Now if I go to the other
account, type a little bit,
you'll see that if I undo
changes here, I'm still
undoing only the changes
made by that account.
So this handles all the
complexity of what can happen
with undo and redo features in
a collaborative environment,
but the code itself is very,
very simple to implement.
And if you want to see how we
implemented this for this
specific example, go ahead and
take a look at the Google Apps
Developer Blog.
And you can also take a look at
the realtime quickstart in
the Drive documentation.
And to show off a little bit
more about this feature and
how it works with more
complicated operations, I'll
hop over to Steve and he'll
take a look at a realtime
tasks application
he put together.
STEVE BAZYL: So this is one of
the demos that we put together
with Realtime API
few weeks back.
It's based on [INAUDIBLE].
And the difference between this
and the QuickStart is the
data model's a little bit more
complicated in this one.
It's a list of tasks and
tasks have statuses.
And we can also do things
like bulk operations.
Things like selecting
all of the tasks and
marking them completed.
When we do things like that that
we want to be one logical
operation from an undo
and redo perspective.
And to do that, there is part
of the API in the realtime.
API is this notion of compound
operations and within a block
of code you can just say begin
compound operation, make a
whole bunch of changes,
and then when you're
done, say end operation.
And from an undo and redo
perspective, those things are
then treated as a single
operation on the stack.
So you can see this, actually
if you can for the demo just
do a select all on
everything and
then try a clear completed.
If we undo that,
what you see is
everything just gets restored.
If we didn't do the compound
operation, what would happen
in this case is everything
would get cleared in one
operation, but if we tried to
undo them, they would all be
undone individually.
Which is really not what would
be expected from a user
perspective.
So it's really easy to do.
I actually just did the code
for this yesterday.
It took me about, probably
about five minutes to add
undo-redo support.
Probably the hardest part
was figuring out
where to put the buttons.
But the code for this is really
trivial and you can see
this on GitHub, Google Drive
/ realtime Tasks and
just check it out.
It's really, really simple.
There are some weird
cases with this.
One of the things I want to show
in the QuickStart is some
weird cases that can happen
around conflicting changes.
So Greg, I think you had
discovered this the other day.
An interesting case where you
could have an undo, which is
effectively turns
into a no-op.
GREG KNOKE: Right.
So for example in this case,
if I undo or if I type the
word test one account and delete
in the other account
and then undo those and then
retype, I can't remember
exactly, and then try to undo
it, you'll see it takes a
while before undo actually
starts to do anything.
That's because when trying to
undo words that the one
account is typed and then they'd
been deleted, the undo
turns into a no-op.
So you can't undo
typing a letter
that since been deleted.
STEVE BAZYL: Right, and this is
actually the same as even
if you take out the
concept of undo.
If you were to type into a
range, in a list, or a string
that another collaborator
deleted that range.
When those changes get resolved
and transformed, that
is a no-op operation because
you're deleting into an area
of text that doesn't
exist anymore.
When those inserts or deletes
or transformed, you're
effectively into the
same situation.
So even though it's a little
bit odd from a user
perspective, when you start to
think about how the underlying
technology works and
transformations, it actually
does make some sense.
There's probably somethings you
can do to probably make
this a little bit easier for
users and developers.
We had an idea of maybe like
fast forwarding a little bit.
Trying to find things that
are actually undo able.
But it is as it is now, it's
predictable, it's consistent
with the way that regular
inserts work today.
GREG KNOKE: Thanks again for
tuning in for this Google
Developers Live and if you want
to see how we implemented
any of the code in the
QuickStart start or the
realtime tasks application, go
ahead and check out our code
repo on GitHub and also look at
the Google Apps developer
log and the Drive
documentation.
STEVE BAZYL: And of course you
can always ask us questions on
Stack Overflow or on the
Google Drive Developers
Community and we're always happy
to talk more about the
realtime API and of course hear
that you're building.
GREG KNOKE: All right,
well thank you again.
STEVE BAZYL: All right, see
you guys next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]